TJ Miller's coming in CJ Sullivan is
with and what's up guys welcome we're
just talking about have the most boring
but prolific trolls on the Internet
why are they boring they just don't ever
have a fun or mean thing to say
streaming I'm sure you could I mean
you're engaging them now so I'm sure
they just say something hateful
well said they're like well I hope when
they say one of them's like well I hope
that Jim is ashamed of the guests that
he invited today I'm like middle school
teacher shame somebody well we were just
looking at cameo you know because you're
on cameo yeah and I'm about to do a
cameo right after this we could do a
live cameo actually but we have to pay
you six hundred twenty-five bucks for it
no I'll do for you guys so what do you
think about it what did you okay so I
think that you're one of the few people
that we were talking about like the
strategies behind this so Brett Favre
just got busted accidentally recording
an anti-semitic video because some
people have paid a file yeah it was very
coated this other group goes like this
they go can you do this cameo it was
clearly an ad for their internet startup
company that's not how this whole thing
works
you don't hoodwink me into like where
it's that so you can't turn it down yeah
absolutely and a big thing for me was I
was like you know this seems to me like
a really cool place for people to get
shot cuz I do some shoutouts for fans
just on Facebook if it's a request
that's nice or but if it's for somebody
I think that's really cool
you know I think that's a nice thing but
yeah the idea that they would sort of
like neo-nazis are like I'm gonna get
him to say something that means the
backwards sign for the Native American
swastika like right where that is is
[ __ ] ridiculous but it seems like I
mean it seems like pure troll bait
champion like okay so why wouldn't you
try to [ __ ] with a celebrity on cameo
but here watch this
an example of one this is for will so
his brother and you you love my work I
want to wish you a happy birthday and
then he says smoke something up Canada
so that doesn't even mean anything but
it's supposed to sound cool and party
art office Christmas party style etc etc
thanks man and this was on Sirius XM as
well so Wow and then I need a little cut
though you just swung it back to me I
mean I need a little love oh you're
gonna get some money okay here give me
$75 cash I'm not no Jews are the devil
at the code I mean that was sort of you
know that's the thing that I had a
friend reached out to me lamorne Morris
is really funny it was like this is cami
a thing I don't know if I should do it
the people because some of the people on
there like Bam Margera is doing it for
$50 and I guess he's making seven
figures really ya know he's a cameo
singers if you can make a hundred and
one thousand dollars make a hundred
thousand dollars and forty four dollars
yes good Bonnie yeah I mean I guess but
I don't I mean it just seems like
there's a part of me I think that you're
smarter in the sense that you charge a
whole bunch of money so you only need to
do a couple of them here just I
shouldn't even do it she's like this is
ridiculous I don't think you know but
here's my thing is like if it's for
someone if that's like an anniversary
present I think that's kind of a cool
thing and I'm happy to do it you think
no though if there's there's something
about it you get off today because you
just said that there's something about
it that feels like you're selling a tiny
little part of your soul like a little
bit feels like it's just like okay
you're making a ton of money you got I
can't be no money in your dollars okay
good because that is this from the cameo
you know how do you feel about it now
yeah it seems like actually a pretty
funny way to communicate with fans
and you know it's like movie pass it
makes sense you know I mean I'm an AMC a
Lister Armand Stubbs whoa so you get to
go right to the front of the line that
works it works $20 a month I see three
right we go on the road and we see
movies at AMC we just figure out what's
playing there we saw skyscraper right CJ
yeah I am an MCA Lister that's amazing
yeah but they like which so we were
looking and like it seems like you're
doing pretty well and one of the most
expensive ones on the plough because
you're $625 guy that's more than brett
favre charges where our Z charge 500
bucks that's around Hanukkah scheduled
it but like our friend man our friend
Matt Iseman from American Ninja Warrior
yeah I love him 25 bucks exactly well no
or you think I just made 75 bucks learn
a cameo or you think of it like this
it's like you know for 25 bucks from 50
bucks or Heather McDonald friend doesn't
$400 it's just like an easy way for her
to make cash and she might be doing that
anyway on Facebook you should get on and
an exclusively do anti-semitic Brett
Farve
I just I won't do it unless there's
something bad about Jews comments came
from the Chicago scene with the ALMS
animal and come on all of us while you
were gone we found I do yes thank you
actually love it the sparkling water
there you go I appreciate cuz we were I
brought that deep-dish pizza last I do
and Norton looked at me like I was a
fool a damn fool no I appreciate
actually a good Larissa is an any good
man's fault Christa Stefano is on cameo
okay 20 bucks yeah I wouldn't I I don't
need the money that bad ice TJ doing 625
I get no I say hey man it's worth it if
you do it Sam said I should get off of
it until he got $75 and I guess good
have you done any yeah yeah I did one
just now I'm here and and then I've done
a couple because I was at 325 but to me
and even Kate was like just seems weird
that you're doing that in general and so
I felt like 625 is not like you
you guys know Chris D'Elia right yeah
using it for $1,000 he's never booked
one cameo never but yeah it seems like a
joke we're at $625 I'm like I'm gonna do
a few of these a year and they're for
people that clearly won I was telling
him somebody with like does that me one
that was like hello everyone I'm Erlich
from Silicon Valley please enjoy this
stick in this tech startup and you'll
make more money than aviato like it was
so clearly an ad for them that's not how
this works
oh you didn't do it no yeah like I want
to charge $800 I think I think I'll sign
up for 800 I think you should be the guy
that's like five thousand two hundred
thirty dollars and you do one once a
year and that's just bragging rights for
the person it's like Amex Blackheart or
something right like super premium level
kami or the dj khaled booked any though
but then there's been no videos of you
or once humiliating if there's only
[ __ ] one video you just make a whole
bunch of fake ones you commit you can
make one and you should make one that's
like whoever does this cameo in my
opinion is the richest coolest person in
the world and that's that's true I'll
probably end up being me
how much is riffraff charging 50 bucks
that makes me think of all the price
though or do you say what you want about
you see what your prices
okay and you know my thing was they also
were like they go you know you should
maybe price yourself low or just stir on
a mic that's cuz you're getting 25% so
you would love it if I was doing it for
$75 right and did a hundred this is not
my job you know my job is to entertain
children between the ages of four and
twelve in a narrative that doesn't
totally make sense but yeah and you know
they're adding some people but the other
problem is and this would a lot of
people Holly were saying is that you
know you look at the people that are on
there and that's part of the problem too
is like I'm on a site where Tom felt an
actor from Harry Potter and Paul
Rodriguez skateboarder and Bridget
Marquez right so it's like the company
you keep is not exactly that's why you
had a fat Jewish and let's
if he does yeah but that Jewish one yeah
how much is that is 150 350 Oh 350 but
that's why you have to tear yourself up
if you're gonna be on the thing with all
these other people you have to show I
mean you shouldn't go through my maybe
the most expensive one I fear I'm a
thousand caitlyn jenner's $1,000 jordan
Belford from the actual guy there wolf
wall she's based on how much you guys
think he is I I know exactly because I
got drunk two years ago and paid I lost
$20,000 for the platforming system six
hundred and ninety six dollars and
ninety cents oh so good scared it's how
much 619 696 dollars and ninety cents
that's a palindrome making fun of Sid
the 69 I think you know what you nailed
it god it's pathetic that was a 59 joke
yes t9 joke yeah how much is that feel
about that six hundred and ninety six
dollars and ninety cents I even get a
couple of sixteen maybe not all right
Wesley Snipes sneaking in there I know
well that's a taxing real how much it's
like there are like you look at him
you're like he is he's the the last
thing you remember about Wesley Snipes
is not passenger 57 its w-2 it was on
yesterday has to do seven tweet yes it
was great right oh my god a very
believable film you thought so yeah yeah
yeah there's always five cops with a
[ __ ] hostage problem snakes on a
plane done right I think yeah I mean you
know you look at that and you're like
alright he's still having a tough time
how much is George John constant from
hello-o like he's the guy that the movie
bring him in but he couldn't because
they're both felons 50 bucks George he
was like the cocaine kingpin of America
I think that's the problem is that the
most part it looks like people are like
I gotta do something but that you know
that's the thing I was actually
targeting Debbie Gibson Norma Karl about
this that it's like you don't have to do
that or tell or anything it's the
standard thing you can always just stand
up yeah always a place to make money
doing stand-up so but like you know Ben
Higgins reality star Andy Milonakis is
like how is he
making money besides posting scream
screenshots of things that other
celebrities say about how much really
yeah no way more seven way more views
yeah Maddie's never okay way more cameo
where you cut to him and you give them
20 bucks yeah
percentage-wise 70 dollars is way more
than fifty dollars it's almost 50% more
this will be forever known as the chance
a math door 69 show ya how much you
soldier boy tell him behind a buck
because they got him with a with you
know what though he does if you've ever
looked at his social media which I have
embarrassingly I'm not embarrassing him
out he does videos all the time he's
like he's living through Instagram he's
looking up line showing his necklaces
and being like hey you know the Soulja
Boy tell him I'm walking over to the
fridge right now get you back I'll get
back at you once the fridge is open and
then a couple seconds later he's like
fridges open looking at the orange not
to I'm gonna hit you back when I'm
headed away from the refrigerator than
five minutes okay I had it away from
refrigerator and it just goes on and on
and so I think he doesn't care because
they already there anyway it's things
like I'm doing this anyway I don't do
anything used to forget I and video
myself hey 100 bucks alright you do say
so you do seven or eight of those a week
you know what is that [ __ ] that eight
hundred bucks a week twenty two hundred
a month
it's like 25% to can be a merger I guess
does so many that he's making eight
figures that's the big cameo thing but
then you're the other problem with it is
is this guy text me out of the blue
alright TM here's and he's like hey I
went to school with your younger sister
at Duke I'm the CEO of cameo and I was
like I gotta get off this [ __ ] it's
make text the sisters friend is texting
me like hey I'm the CEO of the startup
it's who's in New York Times is one of
the great you know 50 greatest companies
of last month like so we'll see what
happens
damn one Pam's like early on it's like
50 bucks I think you do
like Benny just hit some out old how
about no good about David soul from
Starsky and Hutch of course Oh
Timberland values booked wait didn't he
get in trouble was it tapers all got in
trouble for grabbing a girl's ass in a
play it might be why he's not available
well you know and then and then you put
the chart available and they're like
notify you and then cameo is like you
three people are waiting to hear if
you're available that's over however
much you know they tell you how could
you that's like 1,800 bucks but it's
those people just want to hear when
you're that's not bookings oh I see
you're a little bit they've been very
nice but it's a little scamming well
yeah it feels a little scary it's no
movie pass how long's no AMC a-list
stubs member hell all of the videos 10
seconds yeah you don't have to do them
that long how are you unavailable the
door was 10 seconds selfie video yeah
that's really busy wasn't Scandinavia
and then I was unavailable I guess let
me see uh who's gonna cost more on the
variety like Network I got a bad signal
here let me see one of Tommy Lee's I
want to see one of Tommy Lee's video
looks Lee I want to see what the video
looks like he doesn't shave for them
Eric's birthday okay oh yeah what up
it's Tommy Lee's get ready to party your
[ __ ] asses off for Eric's 40th
birthday in Tahoe whoo I was just there
not too long ago that old [ __ ]
can't wait to see y'all
also happy birthday to Jason Kevin
Stephen Shawn and Stacy much love y'all
rock that [ __ ] that was almost like too
much yeah you guys are very well going
to be the reason I get off cameo in 13
minutes what did you think of Tommy
Lee's birthday wishes Jim where do you
think Jim it made me uncomfortable party
your ass off man we both do it's not
that great of a platform
I think I might sign up for 800 bucks so
I don't know I mean yeah you know what
if you do that then I'll price myself at
818 dollars and 18 months like that
smart that's an 81 joke what I mean I
saw that one and now I don't feel good
about myself
not just the Cameo thing I think if you
watch that didn't see Ju we all felt a
little bad after watching that Tommy Lee
I'm making $80 yeah enjoy Tahoe I was
recently no they're actually a funny
story a little much yeah I'm not gonna
he's trying to personalize it so you
feel like you're getting your money
because you're I suppose guilty like
Jesus Christ lady there is something
that like in your in your soul you're
like should I be charging people to just
talk for 10 seconds but then again when
you see that cold hard cash I know I
don't have that problem and you know the
thing is though - it's supposed to be
like a personalized video for a fan
that's their ideas that it's just
shooting your autograph
so it's like is this sadder than
somebody being like hey I know you're
arguing with your wife outside of your
own apartment right now but would you
mind taking a picture so just smile
quickly have you had let me it's not
random it's happened twice in the last
week guys arguing outside
yeah and somebody'll come up and be like
hey I hate to do this I hate to paly
clearly we're in the middle of talking
about she'll be like well if I was them
I wouldn't act like that and I'm like
yes if you were them you would like act
like that and she's like no I wouldn't I
wouldn't be that rude and I'm like but
if you were them if you would face the
obstacles they face have the resources
they had had the child and in the life
that they had you would act exactly the
way she's like no I wouldn't and then
somebody's like hey I work in tech just
do it and get rid of them right and then
but you know sometimes I'm like hey man
I'm sorry we're like in the middle of
something and they'll be like oh really
well it was you know my girlfriend
wanted me to take the picture with you I
didn't even want to come over here and
then you're like now I'm in this
conversation now I'm arguing with a
stranger so the Kami almost flying
higher
call me we do my cameos and just like
outsource it to him how much is Tommy
Lee OD pretty fine let's find out how
much that is because Tommy's 300 300 so
you still get a nice profit off of that
Kabam 300 I keep 325 we give Cammy other
cut I mean maybe pay the cutout of
Tommy's in regions you have any that you
looked at and you were like oh that's
something I'd like to invest in that's
something I'd like to process
I actually I would be lying if I didn't
say I was looking just in case like
someone I knew have no one that I think
I'd pay them money for I thought that
video was really funny I was like a
Groupon Tommy Lee video because at the
very end he gave it like five other
different birthday shoutouts what's the
document they all went in okay so wait
so you kind of liked it was funny
because there was like five names
mentioned which means that theoretically
all five could just split the money
let's see we should all split a Matt
Iseman cameo everybody puts in like you
know $3 dollar 75 now we get Matt Iseman
to just shout all of us out all right
let me see the the Cayden color one for
Tommy Lee cuz it's dark like the videos
dark he's shot in a recording studio
let's see if it brightens up a little
yep okay Haydn 13th birthday dude it's
Tommy Lee wishing you a wonderful and I
hope super badass birthday all right my
man yeah happy birthday bro
if you charge that much do you feel
obligated to do this you go to mine go
to mine what's up Tommy didn't he didn't
have anything to say not funny it's like
but it also it doesn't it kind of
matches that I'm always like it's me
from Yogi Bear 3d in the emoji movie but
I or it confirms that it's actually real
and sad okay let's see let's let's rate
TJ Miller's cameo so I'm glad you're
here for this thanks yeah we can find
out personally be humiliated perhaps we
can find out I do the one do the one in
the yeah for og Sarah
how does one find time to be head of
product in terrific
and still draw the bike ride laser cuts
make toys and eat shitty British East
extract what is going on
please stop do it for your own good
helping but you're a multitasker of the
art tone
your triple fam loves stay cool
always remember keep it oh geez not
Jimmy I gotta get back to cookie
incredibly small sausages nah not much
pie all right Thank You TJ forgotten
look I'll say this about TJ she did a
longer one what's I'm working you know
there's some there's a set there's you
wrote a little bit of material for it
the camera 40 yards away yeah the audio
yeah the audio was unfortunate on that
well that was like the Nick's film in
the Kennedy assassination read what did
you say he's got a five-star rating one
reaction I've always loved lip singing
or sinking sinking thanks TJ did you
lip-sync for one of them yeah I think so
so there you go you know I try and I try
and keep it I guess on brand but it's
considerably I like to yell mystic I
mean I don't care that much about it I'm
not trying to like make a living off of
it but you'll shout out like the you'll
make reference to characters that you're
not doing anymore you're not like - you
know that guy who's gonna go no I'm TJ
here I'm not gonna talk about my Silicon
Valley because I'm in the room that
you're being polite about it even the
avianna thing it's like a little bit
cheesy
can we see one more Tommy Lee video
there's something to that you know oh
this is addictive this is complete one
more Tommy Lee one yes one more I like
Tommy
this shows slowly becomes just you guys
watching cameos every day you check-in
there's only three of them available
well we didn't see did we see Colleen
schedule control by the way Tommy Lee is
doing very very well on cammy all right
the crows your giant dick let's the
bottom right bone with the shades I like
the shape for Tom sure okay yo Tom come
on dude you can't [ __ ] drizzle and
catch up on something dude you got to
dunk that [ __ ] [ __ ] dunk never
drizzle bro what are you doing Wow who
[ __ ] drizzles ketchup come on Tom get
it together bro yeah [ __ ] right Jim's
face is enough to make me regret that
this forever here's the thing like I
feel like that's I get what was going on
there it was an inside joke and he's
gonna show it to his friend now and be
like see I told you you don't drizzle
but he's like Tommy Lee's do in the
drizzle bits but if my friend like
showed that video to me I go you you
paid for this this is so stupid
I think he just asked for a happy
birthday that was all improv oh maybe
UCB for two years I really was I mean I
think there also is a world where we're
talking about this because we're kind of
[ __ ] that no people in it and then
there's other people like shut the [ __ ]
up you got Tommy Lee to talk about the
drizzle ketchup thing people have been
making fun of me about that for years I
love Tommy Lee like there is a world
where that's the most exciting thing
that's happened that year I guess that's
true yes right I mean it says cameo at
the bottom of the video so all you have
to do is google that and realize like oh
you just you paid 300 bucks for Tommy
Lee to do our joke that's he's like shut
up I googled it you paid $300 for the
drizzle thing Thank You Man and it
repairs a friendship that's been broken
for years because of the drizzle
comments at the wedding but really I
missed it his cameo is a cameo on the
video when it goes to the person or just
runs on the site
I don't know TJ Miller king of cameo is
here too and I've never bought a cam
here only on the site because they're
brett farr video they play didn't they
didn't how did you know what I thought
you were just guessing and I said that's
irresponsible Reed but you had yeah
had the information being the only
publicity that this thing is gotten is
that somebody tricked Brett Harv into
being race and can I tell you something
Brett Farve is now at the front page of
Cameo yeah they are really banking on
this like you can get celebrities to say
racist stuff for 500 bucks cameo didn't
want to advertise and that Brett Favre
one they didn't splash your name on that
video I mean it's worth we're talking
about it yeah it did work yeah I'm sure
there are people cameo did themselves
right let's see what Brett Favre does on
our on a regular we're gonna have to
watch another one soon exactly you're
like this is really hard to watch be
like but I'd like to see another one
yeah maybe that's the beauty of cameo
Brett Favre yeah let's watch a little
bread Greg for Brian Greg hey Greg Brett
Favre here want to wish you a very Merry
Christmas
and your son Tony tells me that you are
a big Vikings fan so I hope you guys
have a great end to the season skull
god bless see that's it he bubbles with
personality guy being a sports guy you
know what just just buy me a signed
football good luck in the season but
that's what you expect the sports guy to
say you don't need anything more right
what was that code for though it was
against Mexican season ends up well
cross the board yeah when she rather
just have a jersey though yeah but I
mean this is different it's new let me
see one more brett farr oh we get the
time you know what we're all on Tommy's
page looking for an easy I want to see
what he said to furnish a graphic video
you know this related one looks okay
yeah yo fern easy what's up dude I hear
you really extra like so extra that we
saw your elbow in an episode of
Entourage Z production is as bad as
Jason breath so go with God brother if
not you can always go without
he could he could not take two I think
this is not film TJ are you allowed a
second taste yeah yeah I mean you can
upload an actual video look I actually
in retrospect I feel a little bad that I
just did that guy's cameo on the air
really quickly I know I don't feel bad
about it my question cash in hand now my
question is is it the person because
Brett Favre's we weren't like we were
like okay good on him and Tommy Lee I
think in general like if I met him I
think afterwards I'd be like whoo that
was seven dollars worth of weeks well
Tommy's any sense
yeah but Tommy's trying like Brett Favre
is not trying he's just like yeah I'll
say hello and Tommy's going like what's
up dude it's like yeah time just like
white but it's about the side of this
mouth like when you're on [ __ ] paxil
yeah even snorting you might have just
watched the wrong one do you want to
watch one from Dan yet for Danielle
honestly I think that's a good idea
because I don't want to prejudge as
uncomfortable yet this one may be a
whole more give one more
hi Danielle your brother Erik says it's
your 40th birthday what the [ __ ] happy
[ __ ] birthday enjoy the day and never
get tired of your candy-ass wannabe
biker boyfriend Andre give me a shout
one take Tommy I think you're a yeah was
a good one he's definitely yeah thing is
like I mean I think for some people
probably BAM it's like I'm just gonna
get high and do these 10 $50.00 cameos
and then I don't know yeah yeah yeah
this is this is my day call it a life a
life riffraff let's watch runner riff
Raff's
this is [ __ ] great riff raff is like
50 bucks by the way he must be going on
yeah yeah yeah you see this in your
exact slap man you got a [ __ ] simmer
down dude there can only be one day all
day of Tony all right you got a [ __ ]
keep your keep your [ __ ] distance all
right one mullet one law per country
just kidding dude you [ __ ] go dad dad
time if you want
let's [ __ ] follow me dad Tony shot -
Andrew Bernstein all right dad
Tony nice put some effort into it yeah
he's got it yes got his cameo look he
puts you know he he always wears that
thing for the cameos or maybe that's
just that day you just did all the same
day and I guess he's those were his
catchphrases and stuff I wouldn't know
yeah you know I think yeah and I think
maybe is something he definitely smelled
my catchphrases what did that's just how
he talked who stitches if you're a
rapper on this and you're like bragging
in your music about how much money you
make and then you go on this and say the
rival makes twice as much better I'm not
going on this how was cameo not on cameo
he should be the face of cameo who uh
there's not a lot I mean I'll uh Lukas
Meacham I wouldn't say he's a big draw
Florida J I don't know him or Sammy
Adams now is this making you question
things TJ Miller as we scroll through I
never heard of anything off immediately
after this yeah it's just seeing Jim
Norton's face after the rebeccablack
from the Friday song Friday let's see if
she said something about four yes here's
the dichotomy it made me embarrassed
what to look at Jim Norton's face as we
watch the Tommy Lee videos like my
parents then it intrigues me when he is
like let's watch another Rebecca Black's
I always have always felt bad for the
[ __ ] beating she took forty bucks you
know what Oh another thing I think it's
the price - forty dollars really party
you can feel bad for the beating that
she took but I would say that once
somebody is charging forty dollars to
record a video of whatever you want
they're not exactly trying to escape the
public eye no no no I don't mean that I
don't care people hated their song I
just kind of felt bad for I did it
tonight show whether one since she was
so nice and young enough let's see what
kill now - terrible innit
be regarding and I hope your brings a
lot of really good stuff for you so
thanks for the support
I hear you're singing the song Friday
which is amazing thing that it's like
eight years later but I appreciate it so
have the best time I'm wishing my best
for you and happy happy birthday nice a
nice girl I love that try to get $40 out
of her pants that seemed kind of
passive-aggressive oh when she goes like
even though is eight years ago and I'm
like hey it's Rebecca Black I just want
to tell you and I love you have a great
I wish all the best for you maybe I just
do all of them as Rebecca Black right
one more buy her know that I don't think
she's being sarcastic no she's nice like
it was just like saying I'm honor that
was nice to watch you're like good on
you for being a sweeper yeah she's a
great video very well lit important TJ
you should do like not only do you have
to say who do you want me to send this
to but who do you want it to be from so
any celebrity you'll just say you're
them oh you know me open I should do
impressions salary fresh what kind of
imprint like if I was like I wish Jack
Nicholson was on cameo
this is so horrible things right
Nicholson so different price if I if I
don't know what have I paid you like $30
and said I wanted a happy birthday from
Jack Nicholson
happy birthday Sam here's Johnny that's
actually really really yeah yeah yeah
I'm 34 that what if it was like 55 and I
wanted Bill Clinton to wish my mom a
happy birthday
his name is Robert mrs. Roberts yeah
happy birthday mrs. Roberts come on over
for a cigar okay happy birthday miss
Roberts you have nicer nicer ankles in
my life okay what if what if I needed I
needed advice I needed an advice video
and I wanted it I'll pay $40 to get an
advice video from Michael Caine you're
gonna burn a forced out okay how about
this
I want four for $80 I want a video for
what to plan for the future is from the
Joker
what's the Joker's plan for the day
what's he gonna do is he gonna get
anybody Oh
[Laughter]
$125 Thomas Jefferson it's saying a lot
of my aunt Chiana I don't know what he
sounded like well that's the idea
I know so now you lack of improv free
rein no it would be a good suggestion I
don't know if that's gonna be real
honest about what just happened
I knew the direction I wanted to go in
with Thomas Jefferson
any fire yeah no yeah you make a good
call 6m what if what if I wanted to
I'm getting my I was I'm giving my dad a
watch for Christmas cool and I wanted
Christopher Walken to send him oh I sent
him a message
Oh mr. Roberts a cat's watching my ass
it's great impression you are you are
right you're rigging up a tab
k-fed goes for 75 bucks does he can we
see any of cafes videos yes
sniff his fingers 450 on the Nikki
though I do an impression of Pete Holmes
oh yeah it's just me talking he's ripped
off my entire charisma and persona is
that Ryan crazy okay let's see what that
k-fed very bad how you cook for Kelly
cook with the hoodie on hey it's Kevin
Federline here I just want to give a
happy birthday shout out to Kelly cook
happy 30th birthday I hear you're a huge
fan I love you for that
I also want to shout out your son Sam
and your husband Jimmy you guys get
Kelly everything she wants for her 30th
birthday because she deserves it all
right take care you guys I feel like
that counted as a shout out to me and
you too Jim it did that was cool yeah it
was nice k-fed to the man so I've been a
fan of Pope about fan of popo's out for
a long long it's a great song it's a
great song that's the guy that I used to
be an audition rooms with and he was
really by the way poppers that was
really good he was really good he did it
live oh yeah almost granny introduced
him he's great moment is there sorry did
you say in my ear that our channel mates
on the on the Travis said that Jason
Ellis is on is on cameo Michael Ralph
words on there yep how's it Rapaport get
well I want to see what Jason Allen yeah
I'll check but rap was ready champ oh
yeah how much he gets better how much
you get right there call now I think
it's like 85 is that is yeah look hocks
alright I know what I'll watch is Jason
video Jason Alice video mm-hmm yeah
see because we also got to make sure
that we don't charge less than him yeah
I'm gonna guess he wants 50 50 bucks
yeah yeah I was gonna go for 825 what's
happening that I came on the show expect
you to talk about City Winery tonight on
Tuesday City Winery tonight so yes oh
it's gonna be joining me tonight the
City Winery in Soho South Houston I'm in
Albany New York at the funny bone and
I'm regretting my appearance on cameo so
if you don't want it you can either see
TJ Miller on your tiny little phone
screen for six hundred and twenty five
dollars or for much less money yeah you
can see them in person for an hour at
the City Winery tonight for a for a bam
margera funny funny bone in Albany this
weekend and then Maryland on Sunday and
Ohio on the 14th and st. Louis on the
20th and all over the place TV mother's
not over website.com
let's take a look at this one for Angela
I also hope you have a human being in
your vagina growing right now as we
speak that's gonna be crazy right having
a human being like kicking around in
your [ __ ] cuz like I'm always kicking
around in there myself but it's like
I've never really understood I guess
when people put things in my butt it
might be kind of similar I don't know
it's gotta be wild or just to have a
human growing in my butt so I don't
understand it so it's gotta be really
complicated I'm sure and I'm very
excited for it I'm happy that year
containing the beast in your beef and
then you're gonna have a great birthday
7031 I said yeah Jase is kind of my
favorite so far
laughs Jason talks for a living so he
can kind of just he can actually do one
that seems natural and happy himself I
do one for Stevie what's up Stevie this
is jason ellis and this is Berger Ellis
and we heard that you've been sober for
over a year and you got people that
really love you that want to pay me
money because I'm a talking prostitute
and they really love you and they care
about you so much that they told me to
tell you
it's a good effort and as a person that
struggles that is a [ __ ] solid effort
so keep it going do people really care
about you keep it going all right brides
Doogie I don't usually do that God
killed it and Jason - the best is are
the best so far and I apologize TJ no
Chris easy it was too far away
TJ it wasn't even here at around here
yeah it was moving yeah yeah I think
maybe they need to be inspirational more
like Rebecca Black
Plus not not like a crust not not be
Tommy Lee from across the street but
it's not enough money though cuz you're
doing all these like fifty bucks I mean
I know it's easy but it's like you
there's seven of them that's not like
$350 - 25% so that's like 80 bucks
you're making like - seven it's not a
lot of money I know I wouldn't do it for
less than you're thinking read 300 bucks
I would say you should go 300 maybe 325
325 or 350 or something yeah I don't
know though but you know what when I was
325 on there I got how much is fortune I
when I was seeing that I got a you know
two of them or something like people
don't if you're over $100 it's a lot of
money Jeff Harrison be on there yes
Tripta version should be on for like but
really like six $69 like something
really on the nose for like $4 $6 and
animals that do it for $1 there's like
an animal section that has or $1 and
like someone records the an one yeah
let's buy 75 of those yet say I think
chips should be on for like $69 I don't
know it looks like the objects on this
is pretty bad I hate to be the guy that
can bone yeah oh honey 20 bucks
oh he does everything in the red sweater
- smart
this is Brent it is it's all recorded I
will send you the link in a little bit
no could you hit a game play again
it's all recorded I will send you the
link in a little bit hi this is Ken bone
you're probably wondering what happened
to drew wears socks
well I've taken it over it is now Ken
bone wears a sweater from here on out
this Instagram account will be pictures
of my glorious red sweater ha ha
later boneheads $20 to humiliate
yourself let's see this boy like him
though let's see the swine skin 1 yeah
this is a good one it's all recorded I
will send you the lead he hasn't taken
it down yet leave it like that makes me
wanna get it get a bit that makes me
want to get a Ken bone video just in
case I get a [ __ ] up please give me that
Dylan swoggle pasti a pro-wrestler
yeah that's Hornswoggle yeah I guess I
mean I get why this would be big for
wrestlers do you set up the production
values to good like is there a certain
thing do you want to seem personal like
they're on their phone oh good question
on screen right like that's that is a
good question I've done so many of these
for fans like hey so-and-so's birthday
you know it's like I've you know usually
thing I do for free on Facebook it'd be
nice so I was like why not make a little
scratch on it but now let me look at it
I'm like yeah why I'm behind the grill
trying to do something but it's very
strange yeah it's really yeah I don't
know if I would want to do it I just I
don't know where would you price
yourself if you did to it I mean it
wouldn't be that much tip should do it
chip should do it yeah not me
yeah $69 $69 what trip should do it for
you have way too many requests though no
I don't think it's chip I think it's 69
colors chip has to do it at $69 okay I'm
just saying timewise you know it's just
so on the nose and dumb you know yeah
it's worse than Jordan Belfort 666
telling the best nobody nobody would buy
it
yeah that's hundred $60 is that we write
on brand could add 69 cents yeah yeah
that's true